So security planning, of course,
has to address this question of what
sort of controls make the most sense
given our assets and
given our threat, posture, and so on.
So what are some of these controls?
So first thing that you have to worry
about is identity and access management.
This should come as no surprise because
you've been talking with authentication.
That tells us who is making a request
for any kind of resource we have
in the system, and
then we have access management.
So Identity Access Management is
a buzzword you hear all the time.
Access management basically says if
somebody is making a request for
a resource, do they have permission
to access that resource?
So, credentialing is essentially
deciding that the person is,
we're not going to worry about what you
need to show where to show who you are.
And based on that they're going to
create an account for you.
And they're going to decide what kind
of access should be granted to you.
Using passwords, then, for example,
you may have password policies.
How long the password has to be.
How frequently it has to be changed.
We talked about the Georgia Tech
policy for example.
Some places may have a multi
factor authentication for example,
they may require that you have
a token in relation to a password and
things like that.
Then we have our assets we are talking
about, we have networks and
we have hosts, servers and
desktops and so on.
So we have to have defenses for
those as well.
So we may have firewalls who control
what comes into our network or
our that leaves our network.
We may have Intrusion Detection and
Prevention Systems to look
at the traffic with the network level
then look at network traffic or
host activity, and so on, and
decide if there is something
suspicious that may be going on.
Another controller solution
we might acquire is that
people have anti-virus systems
running on their machines.
People talk about their effectiveness
and question how good they are,
but there's not going to be one solution
that takes care of everything or
one control that takes
care of everything.
They all help you increase
the level of assurance, as we said,
that you are secure.
So we may require this.
If people access our system, the
network's from outside, we may require
that we have a VPN solution,
a Virtual Private Network solution.
If they bring your own devices,
that might necessitate something else.
We know that the software,
we are talking about systems and
controls, so
the software we run on our systems may,
vulnerabilities may be discovered and
patches may become available.
And when we talk about controls I think
we're talking technological controls.
These examples of course, password
management or identity management,
firewalls and so on.
So it looked like those, but not a
control is how do we educate our users?
So this could be, for example,
some sort of periodic thing you run.
We've seen many companies, for
example, to educate their employees so
they don't fall for phishing attacks.
Monthly or they have these things
where they send you an email and
if you fall for it,
this is not a real attack.
This is sort of used to train and
educate you that you shouldn't be
falling for those kind of things.